hey guys it is the 31st of August and
you're watching our gaming news show or
as the case seems to be today what did
EA do today news show EA have said they
could make easy money creating remasters
that the original Mass Effect games but
they aren't planning on it executive
Peter Moore told IGN I was asked a
question once about remasters and I said
it's just not what we do
we've got incredibly talented dev
studios around the world who are focused
on delivering new I paint new
experiences and more and more live
services can we make an easy buck on
remastering Mass Effect yes have a
thousand people asked me that yes they
have we just feel like we want to go
forward there's a little thing called
Mass Effect Andromeda and we're totally
focused on that at Bioware Moore went on
to say the EA won't be pursuing anything
that distracts from Mass Effect
Andromeda and that they simply don't
have the internal resources to produce
free masters J has also responded to the
controversy over there many worst
company in America Awards the publisher
has been named America's worst company
multiple times in recent years by a fan
vote on The Consumerist
they beat out companies like Bank of
America Comcast and B pay for the
privilege more weighed in on the
situation in a recent IGN interview by
saying you try and be defensive and say
this is stupid and this is ridiculous
and then you go maybe there's a kernel
of truth here maybe this is a moment we
can step back at look in the mirror look
at who we are look at how we're
perceived and figure out what we need to
do to do something about it
yayyyy subsequently created an internal
committee to monitor how the company was
perceived on sites like neo goth and
reddit they ultimately decided upon
their player first mantra which is
influenced their attempts to show games
earlier in development offer more betas
and delay games when necessary to
increase their quality finally if you're
having issues connecting to battlefield
ones open beta we're right there with
you and so are a lot of other people the
battlefield 1 beta kicked off for
everybody today after being available to
only battlefield insiders yesterday well
yesterday ran pretty smoothly today this
ship seems to have hit the proverbial
fan players reported being unable
to connect to EAS service and getting an
error message claiming a failure to
connect to EA online a number of
GameSpot staff have run into this issue
on both Xbox one and PC as well as a
related problem where matchmaking fails
there's currently a lengthy thread on
the battlefield forum with reports of
connection issues on all platforms
the official battlefield account has
tweeted that the issues are being
investigated let us know in the comments
if you've been having issues logging on
that is it for me today head to game
swap stories on uncharted 4 and a new
Bioware IP and I will see you again
tomorrow